y quedó fue un panorama de destrucción
más de la mitad de la población huyó de
chernin hiv una localidad histórica al
norte de ucrania poco después del inicio
de la guerra pero con el retiro de las
tropas rusas decenas de habitantes
regresaron al esquí servo un aldeano de
98 años recorre lo que un día fue su
residencia ahora en ruinas recuerda el
día que tuvieron que escapar
estaba acostado en la cama de mi casa
cuando algo golpeó la ventana era la
metralla los pedazos de vidrio volaron
por todas partes
los ciudadanos cuentan que los rusos los
sacaron de sus hogares a la fuerza les
quitaron sus documentos los celulares y
quemaron sus casas
ejército ruso ocupantes y agresores
destruyeron nuestra casa causaron daños
masivos a nuestro estado a cada familia
algunas personas perdieron a sus hijos
padres o abuelos cada familia tiene su
propio dolor forni se mejor
ahora las calles están llenas de restos
quemados de armas tanques y vehículos
militares rusos y ucranianos aunque han
vuelto a casa temen que las tropas rusas
regresen por lo que las autoridades han
habilitado corredores de ayuda y
evacuación la cifra de muertos en la
localidad continúa siendo indefinida
aunque el alcalde dijo que algunos días
enterraban hasta 100 personas
chernick es la ciudad más grande del
país de la que los rusos se han retirado